más elegantes que los costaleros de
sevilla los cucuruchos de antiguas son
quienes transportan las procesiones con
las imágenes de la fe católica sebastián
gonzález figueroa a sus 16 años será el
primero de la fila para cargar el peso
de una tonelada religiosa pues me siento
un poco nervioso y feliz a la vez pues
debido a qué
soy uno más de mi familia en poder sacar
la proyección como anteriormente lo ha
hecho mi papá mi papá mi tío mi abuelo
con la marcha fúnebre de frederic chopin
sebastián y otros 79 cucuruchos levantan
una plataforma conocida en
hispanoamérica como el paso o el anda
encima se mece la escultura del jesús
nazareno de la merced esculpida hace
cuatro siglos y que estuvo tres años
guardada por la pandemia pues
ya
ya está me duele el hombro de
cargar tanto
y feliz
ivonne y penn todos
de día y de noche las procesiones
marchan por las empedradas calles de
antigua los suelos se adornan con
alfombras para simbolizar la entrada
triunfal de jesús a jerusalén
[Música]
un arte efímero que en su versión más
sofisticada cuenta con rolando ortiz
alfombrera experto en el uso del aserrín
se consiguen el aserrín de pino o de
ciprés y para que de los colores vivos
que tenemos utilizamos ácido acético que
es el que nos va a servir para que se
fije bien y en este caso no nos vaya a
manchar el piso desde 1970 rolando se
hinca de rodillas para espolvorear
tapices cuyos diseños improvisa en el
momento mismo en que los pintan
y yo me siento rebién porque tuvimos la
oportunidad de
hacerle su alfombra a jesús
[Música]
ya es una costumbre cada año de semana
santa que las alfombras de rolando
engalanen a antigua la ciudad colonial
de guatemala que además es patrimonio de
la humanidad por la unesco